soit un moment historique pour spacex
comme prévu à 14h48 exactement la
capsule dragon avec à son bord les
astronautes bob behnken et de grelet a
touché mer au large de la floride
un succès pour le premier vol habité
dans l'espace opéré par une compagnie
privée très très heureuse pour faust et
s'extrait heureuse parce que c'était la
phase finale pour c'est pour passer la
certification
c'est dans cette capsule modernes avec
écrans tactiles composé de matériaux
recyclables que les deux astronautes ont
mis le cap sur la terre hier soir 20
heures plus tard les voici les deux
astronautes américains auront passé 63
jours à bord de la station spatiale
internationale sur le 30 mai au
décollage de la navette for clean avec
la capsule cloud drag'on c'est tout
l'espoir américain qui a été lancé en
orbite ce jour là la fin du programme
spatial américain en 2011 avaient
ensuite forcé la nasa à dépendre des
russes pour ses voyages spatiaux avec ce
succès l'entreprise privée spacex
promettent d'y mettre fin en offrant une
navette 100% américaine un moindre coût
[Musique]
d'ici là space x doit conclure 6 allers
retours vers la station spatiale
internationale avec quatre astronautes à
bord selon un contrat de 3 milliards de
dollars accordé par la nasa
l'entreprise del bosque veut à long
terme offrir un service de taxi
spatiales ouvert aux touristes en est
rendu là on est rendu on est rendu à
rêver d'aller sur mars et les premiers
êtres humains qui vont aller sur mars
qui sont proprement déjeuner c'est
peut-être un enfant que vous connaissez
qui deviendra astronautes
en attendant la seconde mission de la
capsule cloud drive est prévue au
printemps 2021 ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal